[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a magnificent
idea by Steven Johnson.
He says our thoughts
shape our spaces.
Obviously.
We build cathedrals
and skyscrapers
and townhouses and beach houses.
And guess what?
He says, our spaces
return the favor.
Those spaces we build, the
architecture of happiness,
as Alain de Botton writes,
the spaces we create in turn
inform, shape, sculpt our
subjective experience.
There is a feedback loop.
We script intention
into our designs.
And those designs,
in turn, script
our subjective experience.
Our ability to create
virtual future possibilities,
both for ourselves
and for others,
to create future spaces,
to inform future thoughts,
to build a thinking room,
to build an idea lab,
to build a creative playground,
to build a backyard that's
going evoke being a child
playing in the yard,
I mean, even the space
we're in right now,
the serene water, the perfect
temperature, the hue coming
from that sky, the fact that
we went around the bend,
we're surrounded by green,
there's no other way
to enter the space
we're in, creates a kind
of womb-like, serene
space, mood, reality,
it's such a wild idea
because, again, going back
to Steven Johnson,
to realize the freedom that
we have to compose our lives,
what Timothy Leary calls the
"vertigo of freedom," right?
Whoa!
I can actually shape this thing?
This chaotic ride is a blank
canvas for me to beautify?
It's fulfillment.
It's awe.
It's Henry Miller's
blade of grass
that, when given
proper attention,
becomes a magnificent
world in itself.
There is so much to inspire us.
And to realize that we
are bound by no limits
in order to drink that
inspiration, it's there
for the taking, were
we to just exercise
a little discretion,
a little discernment,
flex those creative
muscles and make it happen,
we engineer, literally,
our own divinity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah.